today we are unboxing all of the iphone
14s we have the new iphone 14 pro max in
the purple the iphone 14 pro in the
space black and the iphone 14 in this
beautiful blue color so here's the
iphone 14 pro max leather case this is
an ink kind of a navy but it does have a
purple
kind of tint to it as much as i don't
like putting cases on my phone i have to
okay this black looks so good on camera
just moving this around in the light
wow this is the iphone 14 silicon case
this is in the midnight color voila
look at them look at this beautiful
lineup my children i told tim cook that
i was ordering the purple phone you lied
to tim cook's face i did but honestly at
the time i thought that i was gonna get
the purple so which one are you gonna
get the deep purple the deep purple for
sure
yeah oh no did i make a mistake should i
order the purple my precious